This is Kyle and Ariel, a couple who
runs a business that helps other couples
who run businesses. They currently do
about $480,000 per year, but they're
stressed because it costs too much money
to acquire new customers, and they're
maxed out on time. I'm Alex Hormozi, I
own acquisition.com. It's a portfolio of
companies that generate $250 million in
aggregate [music] revenue per year. And
I just happen to know a little bit about
the couplepreneur scenario since I
started acquisition.com and Gym Launch
with my wife, Leila. So, I figured they
got to fix their offer to make it more
valuable to their customers and make it
more scalable so that they're not
responding to individual text messages
24 hours a day. Dum dum dum dum.
>> Hi, Sharks.
>> [laughter]
[gasps]
>> What's up?
>> Hi, my name is Kyle.
>> I'm Ariel.
>> And we are the founders of
Couplepreneurs. Over the last 12 months,
we've generated about 480K in revenue,
206K in profit, which takes us to about
43% profit margins.
>> Okay. So, who do you help?
>> We help entrepreneur couples. So, these
are couples who either run businesses
together or couples where each partner
owns their own individual business.
Typically, the businesses we work with
do about 150K annually minimum, and
their primary desires are to make more
money in business, to work better
together as a couple, and to free up
more time for each other and their
family.
>> Do you know who's the one who tends to
be attracted to the message? Is it the
female or the male?
>> Usually the woman, yes.
>> For sure.
>> Interesting. Oh, yeah.
>> I figured.
>> So, how do you help them?
>> We help the couple grow businesses as a
couple as efficiently as possible. So,
we do this with two offers. The first is
what we call the Rise Together
Mentorship. It's a 12-month program that
consists of weekly group coaching calls,
and this program is really focused on
helping the couple work better together
and just improve their working dynamic.
Our second offer is called the
Couplepreneur Accelerator. This is also
a 12-month program, but it's much higher
touch, and the main focus of that
program is developing a business growth
plan for the couple that's based on
their business model, their strengths
together, as well as their schedule, and
then helping them and coaching them
through the implementation process. We
do also have annual live in-person
events. Our next one's actually coming
up on April 10th and 11th of this year.
>> What's that included with?
>> So, we invite all of our clients to
that, but we also sell tickets to it as
well.
>> Interesting.
>> [laughter]
>> And do you use that as one of the
bonuses for both levels?
>> Yes.
>> 100%. Yeah, it's a fast-action bonus.
>> Interesting. Okay. For offer number two,
the Couplepreneur Accelerator, we
customize an action plan based on the
couple's schedule, the business model
that they want to approach as a couple.
So, we're heavily customizing an action
plan on the front end for offer two.
>> How long does that take?
>> About a total of 4 to 6 hours to go
through everything and then do a call
with them.
>> Yeah. And then the other time constraint
in offer number two is the fact that
they have access to us in Slack like
periodically throughout the week.
>> Yeah.
>> Periodically, what is that?
>> That means at any point they can ask us
questions.
>> I want [laughter] to make sure that we
were clear on that.
>> Yeah, we respond. We tell them we'll
respond within 24 to 48 hours, but they
do have daily access to us.
>> You're slacking all day.
>> Yeah, pretty much, yeah.
>> Ding, ding, ding, we have problem number
one, which is that they have given
unlimited, unfettered, unrestrained
access to them personally, which makes
it very hard to actually run a business.
So, maybe we might be able to sell
people something they still find just as
valuable that they're not going to use
all day, all the time. How do you make
money?
>> The Rise Together Mentorship is $5,000
if paid in full or 12 installments of
$500 a month. For that, the couples get
weekly group coaching calls with Ariel
and myself and the rest of the
community.
>> What's the split?
>> Oh, it's about 50/50. We also record
those calls as well. So, we'll take the
call recordings, we'll upload them into
a training portal where the couples can
watch a replay and they can get access
to other templates and cheat sheets as
well. We have a private Facebook group
for accountability based on the steps
that we give the couples per week. And
we also do these fun things called
quarterly date night challenges.
>> Yeah.
>> This is where we incentivize the couple
to go on at least one date night per
week.
>> Do people like that?
>> Oh, they love it. It's like their
favorite part of the whole thing.
>> challenge is probably like the number
one thing that keeps people buying from
us.
>> Yeah, we're going to we're going to talk
about that. So, with this cheaper one,
basically, it's just a weekly call.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> That's what they get.
>> Yeah.
>> The Facebook group's mostly community,
and then our customer service person
holds them accountable.
>> All right, let's talk about this the
second one.
>> We do the quarterly date night
challenges in both programs, but we also
do a lot more in the couplepreneur
accelerator. So, that's 25K paid in
full, $2,500 a month if they choose the
payment plan over 12 months, and that
includes quarterly two-on-two private
strategy calls where we map out their
action plan.
>> Yeah.
>> Um it also includes weekly small group
coaching calls, which are mostly just
Q&A based. And we also hold them
accountable to their weekly priorities
inside of Slack. This is also where they
can ask us questions too.
>> eliminated Slack, how much time would
you get back?
>> Probably what, 40% of our time?
>> Jesus. There's also the cost of
disruption.
>> I will say though, Slack is usually
people's favorite thing cuz it's like
having us in their back pocket.
>> I like where you're going with this
though.
>> We're going to take some axes out. It'll
be good.
>> That's music to my ears.
>> They made the mistake of running out of
time on their high-touch thing, and then
making a low-touch thing. And the cost
to our customers for the low-touch thing
was the same as the high-touch thing,
which mean all their economics of the
business stopped working. And so, the
real constraint they had originally in
the business was that they were supply
constrained. And so, rather than solve
the supply constraint, they basically
just built a whole another product. What
they probably should have done is just
say, "I wonder if we could sell the same
thing without all of the demand on the
backside for our time." If we did that,
we could sell three times as many
people. So, cool. Do that. If you were
to talk to my team, you would know that
the number one question I ask when they
just vomit a whole bunch of information
on me is I just say like, "What problem
are we solving?" When they decided to
start this other product, they might not
have been clear about the problem they
were solving, or ask the second
question, which is, "Can we just solve
this problem in another way that doesn't
include a starting an entirely new
business, an entirely new acquisition
strategy, and making another product?"
And the answer is yes.
>> So, how do you get customers?
>> So, we use a challenge funnel, which
means we use Facebook ads we run to a
five-day free virtual challenge that we
host inside of a Facebook group. And
then we on that challenge, we do
teaching, training, Q&A, and then we
lead to a sales funnel.
>> How long
>> is each of the sessions?
>> One hour.
>> And what's the drop off between day one
and day two?
>> On average we go from about 9% down to 4
to 5% on day
>> lose half between day one and day two.
Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> And you're getting only 9% of people to
show up to day one?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> So we'll do about six of those
challenges per year and our average ad
spend per challenge is about 19,440.
We do also get some occasional sales
from some other places, one of which is
guesting on other people's podcasts. We
also have a setter on our team who will
reach out to people via social media
messenger and book calls for us and then
we host our annual in-person events,
which some sales can come from as well.
>> What percentage come from top versus
bottom?
>> I'd say 90 to 95%.
>> We really would love to get Alex's
feedback on this challenge funnel
because we spend a lot of money on these
challenges. Sometimes they make money
but other times we'll lose money and
have to spend months recouping the cost.
>> Okay. So what are the problems?
>> So we have three primary problems. Our
first is our cash flow cycle, which
means it can sometimes take months for
us to make back the money that we spend
on new customer acquisition.
>> Tough.
>> Our second big problem is just improving
overall conversion. We've recently
noticed some drop off in attendees for
our five-day challenges, which are our
main way of generating new leads and new
sales. Our last big problem is just our
own time constraint. We are almost at
max capacity for delivering on our
services just due to the amount of
customization that's involved. Fixing
these problems matters a lot to us
because we went through what we call the
anti-honeymoon stage when we first got
married, which is where we were trying
to figure out how to be business owners
but also still a married couple at the
same time. So being able to reach other
couples and help them sidestep some of
the issues that we went through is
really important to us.
>> Okay, so what's sales velocity? So how
many sell a month?
>> So we do these challenges every two
months and this is what a typical
challenge will look like. We'll generate
about 511 leads and or registrants for
the challenge and the average challenge
attendees are 26. So 26 out of the 511
will actually show up to the live
sessions each day. Out of that we will
typically book 12 sales calls, we'll
hold 10 and we'll close six sales. And
currently right now between both of our
programs, we're working with 42 couples
and we've only had four clients turn
over the last 12 months and that's
really just due to payment issues.
>> So right now the company is y'all.
>> Yep. Yes.
>> Zach.
>> Yep.
>> You have a CS person on the back and you
have a setter on the front.
>> Exactly. Yep.
>> What other stuff you got? Do you need
anything else?
>> Because we just use Facebook ads to
generate leads and sales in 2024, here
are the total numbers for the Facebook
ads. There's obviously a lot of numbers
here, but some of the numbers that
really stand out to us is the extremely
high cost for average attendee at $815
and our average attendee show up rate of
5.25%. That being said on the plus side,
if people show up, they have a 49%
chance of booking a sales call with us.
That's why the average attendee to sales
call book ratio is 49%.
>> I just I feel like it we're going to be
able to fix this, but I think it's going
to be really elegant and it'll probably
grow the company a lot and make you a
lot more money. There's a version of the
business that I like that I think would
make this great. [music]
The fact that you like the date night
and everybody likes the date night.
Instead of doing a five-day challenge,
just do it a four-hour date night and
crush the full five four hours in one
pitch. You get twice as many people
there and probably even more will show
because it's a date night and you can
still provide all the value normally do
and then just close.
>> So [music] frame it like couples are
coming to your event for a date night.
>> You actually probably break a record
around that too. Like in the ad, "Hey,
we're going to do the world's biggest
date night." Okay.
>> Cool. I like that.
>> But the thing is that like I we actually
have to solve this back to front. So I
do think there's a better way to convert
and I'll get into the tactics around
that, but like it's kind of a bland
offer. Now, the way that you guys
deliver and all that stuff, fine, people
like it, but I'm just looking at like
what am I getting here? I'm not like
super stoked about it. I would rather
solve for like we have this other thing
that makes us a ton of money. How can we
>> [music]
>> pair that down so that we can still sell
that at that price point, but have five
or 10 times the capacity? We're going to
go deep dive on the offer, so the back
end high-ticket offer. So right now, we
have Slack
the calls, right? 212.
>> Yeah, quarterly 212.
>> Quarterly, okay. And how long is that?
>> The first one is 90 minutes. Every other
one is 1 hour.
>> Okay, got it. What else is there?
>> Weekly group calls.
>> Weekly group, okay. That's not that bad.
All right, what else is there?
>> I would say in addition
>> Yeah.
>> And some modules etc.
>> Yeah, online modules. And then in
addition to the two-on-two quarterly
calls, at the first one we do a deep
dive of looking at their website.
>> thing.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah, so we'll go deep dive. That's That
feels like a separate deliverable to me.
>> Yeah, so the first quarterly call is
longer and it takes more prep time.
>> So I'll just say this times three and
then that one time.
>> Yep.
>> This [music] is current.
>> There's also this other piece cuz you
have this bonus of in person, right?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> So what I'm doing here is before I dive
into recreating an offer, I'm actually
going through the process live with
them, which is I want to understand all
the resources and assets that we have at
our disposal. In The Offers Book, I
cover this in creating your grand slam
offer part two, the trim and stack. The
first part is listing all of the stuff
out and then the second part is, okay,
now we have all these list of things,
how are we going to cut it and combine
it and package it so that it's the
leanest and the most viable. Because
fundamentally, we don't want to just
like offer a ton of stuff. We want to
offer the few things that people really
want and then just remove everything
else.
So this is the $100 million scaling
roadmap and they are at stage three,
stabilize. So they have a very small
team, one to four, and let me read some
of the constraints they're probably
dealing with. People aren't buying fast
enough, which is the cash conversion
cycle. So they're not getting paid fast
enough. They're wasting time with bad
leads. They don't have enough time to
talk to good leads. They're not sure
what to fix cuz everything's going
wrong, right? And customers feel lost.
Now, this one maybe they don't feel as
much on the customer service side, but
they've made up for that by just
providing full-time Slack access at all
times to them. So really they're feeling
lost. We can fix the thing that they
complain about most from a product
perspective, which is this is partially
[music] their complaining about it, but
it's also from a customer angle of what
are all the things that we provide the
most value and then recombining those to
make the most viable offer. Decide on
basic qualifications, right? So they had
this cheaper thing. It's like, well, who
do we really want to serve? Let's make a
product for them, not a product for
everyone, which then ends up serving for
no one. And by the way, if you want to
know where you're at on this scaling
road map, goes from zero employees all
the way to 500 plus, and we break it
down by eight functions, so product,
marketing, sales, customer service, IT,
recruiting, human resources, and
finance. Where people get stuck there,
and how to get through it. This is my
gift to you. It's absolutely free. You
can go to acquisition.com/roadmap.
And if you want my team to actually help
you with this for your business, you can
schedule a call with them, and they'll
dive into the business, and if it makes
sense to invite you out, we will, and
maybe we'll see you here in Vegas.
>> I think you're messing this one up.
>> Okay.
>> I think this is one of the most valuable
things you do. You could functionally
charge $25,000 a year, and have two
getaways a year, guaranteed. And so, you
could say like, think about this as
marriage insurance. We're going to do
all the other stuff, but you guarantee
yourself that you're going to have two
amazing times per year, and when you
look back on your life, most of the
months kind of blend together. It's just
the little spikes that are the moments
that you remember. That's what we're
going to help you build.
>> Love that.
>> I think we do two x per year in person.
And I think you should position it like
getaway, rather than conference.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> that.
>> And also, you guys will have a great
time to get get away, too. So, like,
it'll be fun for you. So, I would what I
would do if I were you guys is, I would
go, do the whole experience with them,
whatever, two days, and then stay two
days after, for you guys. [music]
>> And unwind, we want to
>> Yeah.
>> And what do you think you're going to do
at the in-person event when they're all
there?
>> At the moment, just planning on doing
[music] renewal sales.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah, good.
>> That's what I want.
>> That's a good road map. [laughter]
>> That's it, like early days.
>> That's how we're going to do it. And so,
basically, we have two in-person events,
we're eliminating Slack. That's for
sure. Screw Slack.
>> I'm so good.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah, you're welcome. I feel you feel
lighter. I would almost rather you get
rid of those.
>> The weekly group calls, too.
>> Yeah, cuz I don't think anyone's like,
I'm staying for the group [music] calls.
They probably stay for this.
>> You're right.
>> I think that because when we survey our
clients, the weekly group calls are
usually the least favorite.
>> Let me tell you a secret. What a lot of
people do is that they will try and add
as much as they possibly can. The goal
is value [music] per bonus. Basically,
the way that I think about it is, each
thing we add, on its own, should be
worth the price of the whole thing.
Simplicity is the ultimate [music]
in business. Simplicity makes for a
simpler marketing. It makes for simpler
[music] selling. It makes for simpler
delivery. But, the problem is that
complexity always rears its head. People
want to overcomplicate things. You want
to have four or five benefits in one app
because [music] you think they're all
important, but the reality is that you
weren't able to prioritize the one that
mattered most for the specific avatar
that you're trying to advertise to. We
could include 100 things, but there's
typically only one thing that gets
someone over the hump. People decide to
buy because they hear [music] something
like, "Ooh, that's the one." And then
they're in. And so, we just want to make
sure that we make those details as
compelling [music] as humanly possible,
and then limit the details that we
choose to talk about. To quote Jack
Dorsey, founder of Twitter, "Make all
the details perfect,
limit the number of details."
The main value-adds are we're going to
meet with you, we're going to do deep
dive, you're going to come out twice a
year.
>> Yeah.
>> Love it. If you want to have the group,
I would say this is like for y'all, but
like this is not support. This is not
like you tag me in every single post
kind of thing. This is if you want to
connect each other, then this is the way
Basically, you're more curating the
experience than you are rut doing a
whole bunch of stuff in there. Okay. So,
I think we go deep dive, which is
fundamentally just an onboarding. So,
you'd want to do that anyways, right?
Two and two quarterly times three, and
then you have the group, which is not
going to be a lot. Okay? So, if we're
looking at the total delivery time, this
is 60, so this is 3 hours.
Right? Let's just call this six, so it's
9 hours. And then you have the two
events a year. So, basically, let's just
call it 10 plus this is fixed between
everybody. 10 hours per couple is the
cost. You make 25,000, and so
realistically, the cap is going to be
these two. This is now the new cap of
the business, not all this other stuff.
So, how many quarterly calls can you
take?
>> First initial strategy session does
take, you know, considerable amount of
time, but after that
>> I think we could do five per day.
>> You wouldn't do five per day.
>> You wouldn't do it.
>> Well, I mean
>> Like you can do it physically, I'm
saying what are you willing to do? I
know what you can do physically.
>> I'd say probably two per week.
>> He said five a day,
>> [laughter]
>> not two a week. I'm like, okay, so we
have a 12x differential between you
guys.
>> Maybe five per week.
>> Yeah, five per week. And you do one day
where you just do five.
>> Yeah, exactly. Yeah, we try to batch
them.
>> So that means that you'd max out at 60
cuz you're doing 12 weeks, one a
quarter, times five.
>> Right. Yeah.
>> So that maxes out at 60 clients. I don't
love that.
>> Yeah.
>> I'd love to be higher than that. How do
we get you to 150 clients? That's what
I'd like to reverse engineer. Because if
we get you to 150 at 25, let's call it
30 cuz it's a lot of people going to be
on payment plans, then that takes you to
four and a half, which is 10 times what
you're currently making or earning,
which feels chill.
>> Yeah.
>> I feel on my scale of chill, it's chill.
>> Yeah, I mean it's pretty chill.
>> So 12 weeks, if we could get to 15 a
week, now again, this is what we have to
deliver on. We could
do a smaller group
of four and have it be 90 minutes.
Cuz then in on Monday, you could do four
90s,
six hours, and see 24. And 24 * 12 is
even more than that.
>> Yeah.
>> When you are supply constrained, you can
either raise the price, [music]
so if fewer people buy and the people
who buy you get paid more for, or
you change the ratio of delivery,
meaning you go from one-on-one
to one-on-four to one-on-six to
one-to-many, or you productize, [music]
or you hire people. So we have a lot of
different ways that we can solve a
supply constraint. We're going to change
what we deliver and make it into a
product, we're going to change what we
deliver slightly by delivering it to
more people at once, we're going to keep
it the same number of people but we're
going to raise the price so we make more
per person, or we're just going to hire
somebody else to do it. All of these are
potential solutions, but I'm going back
and forth with them to figure out which
one makes the most sense. They were a
little bit cash constrained and I didn't
get the impression they wanted to have a
big team. The next one is the price.
Now, they were already struggling to
sell the higher ticket thing. And so,
like I don't think we have room to go
three or four times as high because
that's what we would need to do in order
to make a pricing move that would make
sense. So, this one's out. And then we
have the productizing. Now, they already
did a productized version, but they
can't sell it at the price that they're
selling their expensive thing. So, this
one's out now. This is basically the
only thing that's left on the map that I
see as a high likelihood solution for
where they're at right now, which is why
I recommend
>> The other factor, I guess, to consider
is our dream state of this business
wouldn't necessarily involve us being so
heavily involved in Square.
>> Only one day a week.
>> True. That's true. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm working on one day a week here.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, I like I like
that.
>> "I want to make millions of dollars and
work one day." I'm like, "Okay, well,
you know,
>> Yeah. Yeah. That's fair. That's fair.
Yeah.
>> Yeah, our goal is eventually to be able
to have coaches that can deliver on it
as well.
>> Yeah.
>> I will be super candid with you.
>> Please.
>> Most coaching businesses fail at scale.
And it's because if you have some unique
skill set or your personality, whatever
it is, like your X factor, if it's
easy to teach, it's not valuable. And in
order to have coaches who come in who
can deliver the same level of value,
it's going to be hard to teach. So,
either you're going to have the issue of
like, I'm going to bring someone in and
they can walk with the customers, or
more likely, you'll bring someone in
train them up in a weekend and they'll
be like, "This is now the person doing
delivery." Now, then you're going to
claim it's your system and all the other
stuff. But I've never seen really anyone
get above 30-ish million a year in that
space.
>> Okay.
>> And so, the people who get above that
typically have a more distributed model.
>> Okay.
>> So, what I mean is this is y'all's X
factor. So, let's say we have all these
little shot glasses here and on the
other side we have full full same size
bottles, okay?
Scenario one, I just pour this into the
shot glasses.
Okay. Scenario two, I pour it into the
big glasses.
Then I take this and fill it up to the
top so that it's the same same amount.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> [clears throat]
>> What you end up having, this is the
coaching model. You're going to get the
same amount of time, you're going to get
this person, they're not as good as me.
It's going to be really diluted.
>> X-factor.
>> Yep.
>> Versus, would you rather just have a
little bit less, but you have the full
me, the full X-factor?
>> Yeah.
>> And in my opinion, this model still is
better because then you just keep
getting better.
>> Mhm.
>> Now, if you're like, okay, well, we
don't want to be key man. I'd rather get
you to 4 million a year.
>> Yeah.
>> And then we can deal with that problem.
>> When he did the whole Gatorade analogy,
that was very powerful because we don't
want to dilute the value of what we
offer. And for many coaching businesses,
you feel like you have to just by hiring
other coaches to coach for you. So, that
was a really powerful paradigm shift.
>> Every one of these solutions that I just
outlined have businesses that have
succeeded with them.
>> [music]
>> The question is, which problem would you
rather solve? If you decide to do the
hiring path, then you're going to build
basically a firm of partners to do this
service for other people. The problem is
most people who are in this world, who
are influencers or creators, whatever,
they have some sort of X-factor, and
people come for them. And so, when they
try and hire staff, they just say, oh,
here's my buddy. I spent a day with him
to try and teach him my method, and now
he's going to deliver it. If this is
such a complex method, if you can train
somebody up on it in a day or two, it's
probably not that complex. Or, it is
that complex and you're just saying it's
not that complex and just putting them
[music] in front of customers because
you don't want to do it anymore, which
is laziness. And also, you're probably
not paying them what would be required
to get somebody who's actually [music]
as good as you were or better. And so,
the business you build here is a
recruiting, training, and culture
business.
>> [music]
>> If you want to have a productized
version of this, then you're going to be
leaning heavier in a marketing and sales
because the delivery is going to be more
or less automated or productized.
>> [music]
>> This allows you to scale more easily
from an acquisition perspective, but
then you got to learn how to market and
sell at an even higher level. Then we
have these two. So, if you're a pricing,
then what you're really going to get
into is the branding business, right?
Because in order for them to command
[music] super premium prices, let's
imagine they only have 100 customers.
They say, we never want to get over 100
customers and we want to grow this
business. It's like well then the only
thing we can do is just keep jacking
[music] price in this scenario. But the
only way we're going to get people to
continue to buy is that we have to
reinforce this brand loop [music] where
every time we have these 100 customers,
their lives improve by so much, they
create these amazing stories for us,
they bring their friends and then over
time because we have supply and demand,
right? As a as a nice little x factor
here, the price would continue to go up
as demand increased, right? But we're
keeping supply fixed. Now, the ratio,
which is what I recommended for them, I
want to say it kicks the can down the
road.
>> [music]
>> And what I mean by that is they're just
going to get better and better. Just cuz
you get more practice if you're [music]
the person who's got the x factor. And
so they're going to get more practice.
So even though people are going to get
shot glasses of them, it's going to be
more and more concentrated shot glasses,
which means they can keep dividing
[music] it over and over again as they
get better and better. And so the value
proposition actually can stay fixed as
they improve. Ultimate version of this
is look at Tony Robbins' business,
[music] right? We got one guy and he's
on stage in front of 10,000 people and
they all pay $5,000 to be there because
he can command that price because he's
so good on stage that people are still
thrilled even though they're in an
auditorium of a zillion people. In the
ratio business, the business that you're
really building there is that they're
just continuing to do what they're doing
and they're just going to be able to
drive more and more profit in the
business.
>> [music]
>> And we personally enjoy the events
probably the most out of everything else
that we do in the business.
>> This would probably be my V1. My V2
would be can we just [music] sell three
a year? And then I would just basically
position it as listen, right now you're
not spending the money because and you
know [music] you should.
>> Yeah.
>> This will guarantee that you have it.
And also you split up the day so it's
50/50. So it's like we're going to be
doing some stuff together, but like it's
also y'all's vacation. So take the day.
But the thing is is like it's okay
because you block [music] the like the
values you made them block the time.
>> Right.
>> And come out and do and make a cool
experience.
>> When Alex said don't worry about key man
risk, we felt a sense of relief because
we felt like we had to just take what we
do and go multiply it with other people.
But realizing that we can just not have
to worry about that right now and focus
on what it is that we do [music] best
and grow the business in that way, makes
it feel a lot more simple, and allows us
to again just do what we love to do and
serve the people that we love to serve.
So.
>> I think this is V1, but let's solve the
money thing here. If you're willing to
do two days a week, then that would get
you to 120. So that gets you to
three-ish million.
>> It's better than five days a week at
what we're currently at.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Love that for you. Yeah. Okay. So
this to me is
This is no longer the back-end offer.
This is just the offer.
>> Mhm.
>> That's thing one.
By the way, for the record, we do like
serving our clients, so it's not like
they're [laughter] bothering us all the
time. You know?
>> Oh, of course.
>> Yeah.
>> Clients, they're very happy to to to to
to deliver, and they're very grateful.
And congratulations to everybody who got
the $5,000 thing.
>> Yeah.
>> It will never be sold again. The second
thing is going to be our acquisition
model. Okay? So you guys are doing the
five-day challenge. So if I wanted to
make the lowest-risk bet,
>> Yeah.
>> my lowest-risk bet would be run the play
back again, and now sell the thing that
you should have been selling this whole
time. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> [music]
>> If I wanted to be spicy, which why not,
my spicy version of this is you run date
night, and you make it two to four
hours, and then you just pitch right at
the end. So the reason that I'm a big
believer in this is that there's a
certain amount of information that
someone is that is required for someone
to make a decision. We can spread that
in five hours over five days, or we can
do one five-hour session. If I had to
pick between the two, I'd rather do the
five-hour session. And the main reason
is cuz like I can weave a lot more
things in. I can like you're kind of
like in state, you're in flow, it's top
of mind, you're like there, rather than
having to remember each time to come
back to this thing. And so you'd also
have twice as many people that you'd be
pitching to. If your position is a date
night, no one's oh, I'm going to do this
date night for 60 minutes. It's not a
date night. So I think having it be
extended, you already have permission
based on the nature of what a date night
normally is. So this all makes sense.
This is your activity for the evening.
We got you covered. This has already
been demonstrated across lots of
industries that just super long single
day or half-day events can be incredibly
compelling for selling very high-ticket
things. When someone gets 3 or 4 hours
with you in person, they get a pretty
decent vibe about you and your expertise
and whether they want to make a buying
decision.
>> So, they would actually do a real date
night in Justin's hand.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And we're just talking through different
scenarios.
>> think you do them like
>> And this would be like break all the
internet marketing rules. But, you do
them like a Friday night.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, if that's hard, then it's like you
could test it and be like, is Thursday
night? But, from all the math that I've
seen, doesn't really matter what day you
run it.
>> [laughter]
>> So, you can believe whatever narrative
you want, but at the end of the day, I
don't think it's going to matter.
>> Okay.
>> If we were to do tomorrow, I'd say just
run the play you already know. It's
already built out and then just offer
the better offer.
>> So, what we need to do here, and this is
actually super common to a lot of
businesses, you have to pull cash up
front. So, number one, one of my
preferred methods is you can do layaway,
right? Which is you can pay on whatever
plan you want, but you won't get
delivery until you pay X amount. Like,
until you pay a third, we don't start,
but you can pay you can make it as
flexible as you want. But, a lot of
people are like, I'll just pay a third
now and then start the payments.
>> Okay.
>> And then that way you can pull a lot
more of that cash up front.
>> So, we wouldn't even start the service
until they
Got it. But, they can still at least put
their deposit.
>> Yes. You could do an onboarding call or
something like that if you wanted to
just to be like, "Hey, congratulations.
We're excited to have you. You know, why
why I do this community, but we're not
going to start doing the deep dives and
all that stuff until until you until you
pay. The way that that would help solve
the cash flow issue is the idea is that
most people would be like, "Screw it.
I'll just prepay the first quarter."
>> Okay.
>> Now, that's kind of option A. And I
would just recommend doing ask for the
quarter up front, which is basically the
way that it works is it's 9K down. And
the reason we do this is because the
deep dive we do is really intense and it
costs us the most out of everything that
we're going to provide for you. All
right? In terms of our time. Basically,
you sell that and then I would just
immediately start the payments, whatever
it is, 2,500 or 3,000 dollars per month
after that. But, I would start
immediately. It's not like you pay nine,
don't have to pay, and then you have the
next thing, cuz then you're going to
have a churn.
>> Yeah, true.
>> Okay? The thing here is then you
downsell layaway. So, if they're like,
"I can't pay the 9K now." No worries.
Just make three payments and then we'll
kick you off.
>> Okay.
>> Got it.
>> And that's cool because you're also
probably going to come up soon to one of
the event dates. Cool, you're prepaying
this, you're going to be doing a
vacation anyways, might as well just
like think about it like a savings plan.
I don't think we need to complicate this
any more than that. Basically, the fast
action bonuses, you start now.
Yeah. And we do the deep dive
immediately. And you'll qualify to come
to our event. So, if we have an event in
2 months, everybody who prepays can
attend and gets the deep dive. And
you're always going to have one within 4
months anyways if you're doing three a
year.
>> Yeah.
>> So, the only way they come to the event
or get the deep dive is if they pay the
9K.
>> Yeah. Got
>> Okay.
>> Next thing is we're going to go after
position. All right. Let's do ads right
now. What I want you to do is also offer
a $2,500 rebate. As soon as they sign on
and do their first date night, they make
a video of them doing the date night and
what the experience was like. And so
then you can use all those for ads on
the front end.
>> Oh, I love that.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you give them a rebate. So, it's
like it's 32.5, but you get $2,500 back
as soon as you send us the video. And
it's just And it's And you obviously
give us permission to use it. Don't talk
about money. Just talk about the
experience. Talk about what [music] it's
like.
>> Okay. And you would add the rebate cost
on top of the
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, then you take Got it. I got
it.
>> Okay.
>> I'm a big believer in making ad machines
in every business, [music] which is like
I want to have the normal function of
the business create the marketing for
the business. I want a fusion reactor. I
want something that can just
self-sustain. I don't want to have
inputs that's always me to drive the
business forward. [music]
And so whenever I can, wherever I can in
a business, I want to create some way of
documenting stories, narratives,
emotions, outcomes from customers.
[music] Think about how it works in
sequence. One person advertises. That's
me. That starts the engine. Customer
comes in. Customer has great experience.
That experience gets documented. That
experience gets advertised. That
experience from that customer gets the
next customer. So, the only thing that's
really required to get the business
started is me just doing one big
marketing push. And then after that, the
snowball rolls on its own. Okay. So, if
we're looking at these ads, do you guys
ever run video?
>> We've tried, but it hasn't performed as
well for us.
>> Yeah. So, I'll tell you a secret about
video. Video has higher volatility than
images do. But, your best ads will be
video and your worst ads will be video.
>> Oh, fascinating.
>> So, video outperforms images if they're
good videos.
>> Right.
>> Images outperform videos if they're bad.
>> [laughter]
>> You guys make content, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, can you pull up their
Instagram real quick? What's your best
one recently?
>> the one to the top right was the
>> Okay, here we go. To any man who's
married to a strong woman, here's a new
lesson I've learned about masculinity.
[music]
Your wife's strength does not have to
compete with your strength. It actually
complements your strength. The strength
of your wife does not threaten your
manhood at all. In fact, the more you
encourage her to flourish in the areas
that God has gifted her in, [music] the
healthier your relationship will become.
So, when you lead from this place, a
place of collaboration rather than a
place of competition, you actually
[music] become the strong man that you
and she wanted you to be in the first
place. Love this. So, now all we do is
take that,
>> Yeah.
>> run this an ad, and then put a 5-second
CTA at the end. My wife and I have been
working together for this many years. If
you're a couple and entrepreneur and
this resonated with you, come attend.
We're doing a 4-hour date night. It's
going to be awesome. Like, we're trying
to do the world's biggest night out.
Either way, it's going to be a blast.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh it's absolutely free. Just put in
your information. We'll send you a
couple texts to remind you, and we'll
see you there.
>> Perfect.
>> Love it.
>> Love that.
>> That's great.
>> What I want you to do
is cuz you guys are cash constrained
right now. So, how many pieces of
content are you putting out a week?
>> [clears throat]
>> Like, two.
>> Okay. So, what I want you to do is get
to at least one a day.
>> Okay.
>> You're going to use that as your free
testing ground. You're going to take
your highest performing clips and then
run those ads and just slice a CTA at
the end.
>> Got [music] it.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Okay. Perfect. So, we're going to
we're going to repurpose best
performers.
Did you get any business from that?
>> No.
>> Is there any post that you've made that
has gotten you business?
>> The closest we got to that was a podcast
interview that we did where the podcast
hosts themselves loved us so much they
hired us to coach them.
>> Okay, got it. So, what I would also do
is I want [music] you to take that
podcast and slice it up and run the
moments as both organic and [music] ads.
>> I love that.
>> That's the ad side that I would do. Now,
obviously, I think you should also make
normal ads following the standard
advertising process [music] that we
outlined in our lovely leads book. You
can still do the images. I would just
run a ton more of them. Like how many
images were you running [music] for
this?
>> Normal campaigns we do probably like 12
to 16.
>> So, I would probably bump the N on that
to like 100 on images.
>> [music]
>> Just cuz like you just have no idea. You
literally just open up your iPhone. You
have probably a gazillion images of each
other and hanging out. Literally run all
of them.
>> Okay.
>> Just all of them on the image side. And
then this [music] with the organic, that
will give you a good amount on
There we go.
Okay. So, I think if we just did that,
you'll probably be good to go.
>> Um same ad copy that is pretty
>> performing copy usually needs to change
very little. I'll tell you a secret.
>> For school last year, we spent tens of
millions of dollars on ads and we never
changed the copy once.
>> Wow. Okay.
>> Once the copy's right, you just keep
changing the creative. [music] Cuz it's
like this is the message that resonates.
Now we just need to get it in front of
different people in different ways,
different hooks in terms of the
creative, but like the actual words on
the copy more or less the same. Let's do
funnel, which is not really existing.
Okay. So, I do think that part of the
reason that y'all's show up rate is so
low is because you don't actually have a
page.
>> Yeah.
>> So, lead form opt-ins tend to be the
lowest quality overall. I would bet
[music]
that you could probably get somewhere in
the neighborhood of 25% if you ran them
to a funnel. Now, that being said,
you'll get cheaper opt-ins here, but you
won't necessarily get cheaper sales. Cuz
you track CPA, right? Have you ever done
it to a funnel or not?
>> Yeah. Actually, that's the reason why we
currently run lead form ads is because
when we track [music] the CPA all the
way to the back end
>> Yeah.
>> the leads that opted in through the lead
form were the lower CPA and higher
qualified too, which is weird. Like even
our agency said we've never seen this,
but okay.
>> I It's not common. Was that one campaign
that you did that on?
>> No, we split tested it for a year.
>> Yeah.
>> Cuz I even thought I was like this makes
no sense.
>> It doesn't make any sense.
Well, then I'm not going to mess with
it. At the end of the day, the actual
percentage shows and things like that
don't actually matter. The only thing
that matters is cost to acquire. And
would we be okay with a $1,500 CAC on a
$2,500 thing? Yes. Would we be cool with
a $2,500 CAC on a $2,500? Yeah, sure.
And now that we have the 9K, we're going
to get way more of those up front.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you hear the common theme between
probably a lot of these different kind
of episodes that I run with business
owners is that there's many things they
could potentially improve in the
business, but there's usually one or two
that are the big levers on growth. And
for Kyle and Ariel, it's the offer
and the creative.
So, make a better offer, make better
creative, better creative gets us better
leads, better offer gets more of them to
buy.
We sing happily ever after as
Butterworth draws my bath. For now, I
I'll say this, I don't want you to
change it. I want you to stick with what
we have.
Make better ads,
>> [music]
>> have a superior offer. The main test
that we have to basically make the
decision on, which we will by the end of
this, is do we want to run the same play
again or do we want to run the four-hour
date night?
>> It's hard cuz we've been just following,
here's what works, let's just keep doing
what works until it stops working. And
now we're like, well, shoot.
>> Well, it has stopped working, right?
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Now, I'll bet you that the messaging of
the five days probably converts cuz cuz
your conversion has been fine. It's just
been like attendance and stuff. [music]
>> Right.
>> And so, for me, I'm like, okay, well, I
do think that there's probably way more
people running five-day challenge stuff,
and so that's fairly typical. If you
were to run it as a date night, I think
that's a unique angle that is unique to
your business. You can still do the same
amount of kind of presentation time as
you normally would. You'd probably slice
some stuff out, too, cuz you don't want
to do intro outro every time. So,
probably is three hours of quality
content out of five.
>> Yeah.
>> So, that's like, great. And then you can
just do a wrap-up pitch at the end. If
you would change nothing, you'd have
twice as many people there for the
pitch. If the date night converts better
than the challenge, then it'd be even
more.
>> How much of this is like a date night
fun activity versus like what we do
during the challenge, which is very like
tactical heavy objection handling sales,
you know, all that kind of stuff.
>> Well, you still provide value. Of
course. Right. So, just do that.
>> Okay.
>> And you can probably reframe the front a
little bit. Literally just the
introduction, and the rest of it can
probably be the same. If I started out
and I like, "Hey, everybody, welcome to
date night. If you're anything like us,
date night is not business or fun, it's
both. And we're going to do that
together." All right, so let's start
with and then you're you're in, right?
So it's I think there you go, we just
merged it and now we're in. Perfect.
Okay, that's a great frame. You
literally need a frame. That's it. So
what's your upsell percentage from the
in-person events that you have now?
>> So our in-person events, we've held two
so far. Last year was the first time we
had the lower ticket offer.
>> We focused way too much on production
and providing value and like barely
pitched.
>> Yes, so we weren't that intentional. So
therefore, I think we only sold one of
the higher tier program at our last
event, which covered the cost. It'd be
great to like do a lot more.
>> How many people did you close in general
out of the people who attended?
>> It would be like one out of 50.
>> No, but what about to renew on the lower
ticket thing?
>> We didn't.
>> Oh, only one person total?
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, you definitely didn't pitch.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was we went too soft and I know you
say if you're going to pitch, pitch, if
you're not, don't. We screwed that up.
>> So how many days is the event?
>> Two.
>> All right, so number five is meet and
renew. So this is me just planning
ahead. If you just do the stuff we were
talking about, like the business will
probably already triple or more. Not
triple, sorry. If it's 3 million, then
it would be more than that, like seven
or eight X. Okay, so it's you've got day
one, you've got day two. Intro's going
to matter a lot. It's one of the most
important things of an event. It's just
blowing people away. Be on top of it.
It's a lot of little details. Greet them
by name, have specific facts about their
business, about their marriage that you
bring up to each person. I would try and
have a list of people that you can tag
so that Do you have help for these
events?
>> Yes, yeah.
>> Take the list of people who are going to
be there, break them into different
rosters, be like, "You're on A, you're
on B, you're on C, you're on D." You can
give different lanyard colors so that
they can basically know, "Oh, this is
green, this is blue, this is yellow,
this is orange." And then you're in
charge of yellows, you're in charge of
reds, you're in charge of oranges. Make
sure that you tag all of them. They have
a little list and they have the two
facts they're going to bring up to them.
They're like, "Damn, these people are on
top of it." And so that's the in
between. So you'll have your intro,
you'll have meet one, meet two, and then
you have your break, M3, M4, and then
you'll probably have your pitch, and
then you'll have another intro again,
sorry, M1, M2, and then you'll have
lunch, and then I think here's where you
do a soft re-pitch, and then you [music]
do M3, M4, and then wrap. [snorts]
>> Okay.
>> Does that make sense?
>> Makes a lot of sense.
>> Yeah, I would say here I would do a a
dinner of some sort. People who buy get
to go to dinner with you guys. So,
reserve a nice place.
>> Okay.
>> So, that gives them immediate reason.
And then here, this can you typically be
shorter. So, this can usually be like 15
to 30 minutes. That's just say
>> My team tells me X, Y, and Z from
yesterday. So, I want to
>> handle some of those things up front for
you, but I'm going to try and frame this
in a way that's still valuable. And so,
it'll help you with your business, too.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> Yeah, I like that.
>> Yeah.
>> So, teach while simultaneously
overcoming objections.
>> Got it.
>> And that's what the re-pitch is.
>> Yep.
>> Now, for this pitch, would you do like
the full hour?
>> You don't typically need to.
>> Oh, okay. Cool.
>> All right. I'm a big believer in like
just provide value. I think stories and
narratives are really powerful here,
frameworks, things like that. And then
basically at the end, I think just
having like, "If today was valuable, do
you mind if I just tell you a little bit
more about what we do?"
>> Okay.
>> Sure. And then you're talking 15
minutes.
>> Okay.
>> Stack and close.
>> That's it.
>> Got you.
>> You basically just make the offer, let
them know how to get it.
Call to action.
>> And then come to dinner with us.
>> For everybody that does it.
>> Yep.
>> That's a huge relief cuz in my mind I'm
like, "Every single thing we do from
start to finish we have to structure in
a way that I like lead to it."
>> But for right now, you haven't sold
anyone. And so, we're going to start
with
just selling and having a clear offer.
And then just asking again.
>> [laughter]
>> And we're going to leave it there
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Of course, if you weave in some like in
the examples that you use into the mini
sessions, you're like, "Hey, like you
want to weave in the different avatars
both psychographic in terms of what are
the belief systems that these people
have?" And then also, what are the
typical problems that they're dealing
with cuz that'll be different, too. And
I'll bet you of the three, if I had to
pick for diversity, that would be the
one I would want to make sure I had the
most diversity in. The biggest one is
going to be the diversity of objections.
These ones where their business was
crushing it, but their marriage wasn't.
The other ones where their marriage was
crushing it, but their business was
actually causing problems because if
they just had that right, they'd be good
to
Other ones where let's talk about kids.
hitting the different things that
someone's going to bring up.
>> Okay.
>> We all have unspoken limiting beliefs
and the difficulty [music]
is recognizing them. Thing is this in my
book. My favorite quote of all time that
will likely be on my my tombstone is the
value equation. Which is we question all
of our beliefs except for the ones that
we really believe in and those we never
think to question.
And so I think it's such a powerful
statement because we are limited by
invisible chains of our own making. And
so many times in my life I've been
living inside of a cage that I didn't
even know existed.
>> [music]
>> And so they are enslaved to this
business right now because of their
beliefs about the fact that it must be
this way or that there is no possible
alternative reality in which they could
sell people and help them in a non
one-on-one scenario. And all I wanted to
do is just bring in evidence from other
scenarios where people get more help
from being in larger groups not
one-on-one so that people could not be
ashamed. But these blocks exist all over
the business. It could just be from the
price or like no one's going to like
these ads or no one's going to want to
buy this offer. It's like you don't know
until you [music] try it. And if you're
not sure, just look around because if
you're in a tremendous amount of pain,
then you should be incredibly motivated
to disprove the belief that you have
[music]
that there's a way to solve this
problem.
>> Now when you say renewal, are we
renewing into the lower tier offer or
should we
>> No. I think you should only ascend.
>> At what point?
>> For the existing and I would just let
them know, "Hey, we're sunsetting this
and so you guys bought a year or
whatever it is." And so
>> [music]
>> The next thing is that it's super light
on delivery for you guys anyway so it's
not a huge deal and I would sunset it.
So those are the big five.
>> Okay. Cool. So I'm going to recap them
for you and then we'll put this in a
bow.
>> Quick question or two on the renewals.
Like would you do a specific incentive
for renewals?
>> Would I have an incentive for immediate
renewal? Yes. So I'll give you a couple
different ones that you could think of
that you might think is more compelling
or less. You could say, "Hey, for
everyone who renews today, we'll buy you
first class tickets to the next event or
all free events next year."
>> Love that. I actually like it because
the experience really does start when
you leave home. And so it's like you got
champagne on the plane, you're getting
in the mindset. And so what's the total
net cost of that? It's like six grand
maybe? So you can keep the price the
same
>> [music]
>> and you can add that in. Or you could
say a very classic fast action bonus or
something like that. Just knock five
grand off the price.
>> For immediate renewal.
>> Yes. Okay. So renewals for the high
ticket and then lower tickets since
we're sunsetting it would just be
ascension. Okay.
>> In between right now, add in the
quarterly and the deep dive.
>> Okay.
>> For now.
>> And people will pay 25k for that.
>> For sure. I mean the only the other
things are modules they're not using and
cause they don't care about.
>> They do love the slack though. You know,
like they can ask us a question.
>> There's things that people might love
after they buy and then there's things
that people will love before they buy.
I'll give you an example. So at Planet
Fitness they have like a pizza night
once a week. I think it's Tuesday or
whatever. It's like you can get pizza.
>> [music]
>> The reason they do it is because they're
like, "Listen, at the very least you can
come get pizza here and it's going to be
cheaper than this membership because you
get free pizza." So it gets people to
buy. But then people don't even eat the
pizza because they don't go to gym
because they feel guilty.
>> [laughter]
>> But the thing is it's a great little
stick. The reason someone buys isn't
always necessarily the reason someone
stays. Now if people haven't been
ascending then the slack is
takes up your time but it's not causing
them to buy again.
>> [music]
>> True.
>> Yeah.
>> It's just a time suck.
>> So from the outside looking in the slack
isn't necessarily a selling point as
much as it is a something people like
afterwards.
>> The reality of it is that you have
reinforced them messaging you all day.
>> True.
>> Yeah.
>> So they message you and then the latency
between you responding then reinforces
them doing that which means the group
probably not super active. Your slack
messages are super active.
>> Yeah.
>> And so it's like we want to redirect all
of that activity to the community
because think about all the value that
lives in all your slacks. Right now it's
to no one. So if someone's going to ask
you a question, I'll answer for
everybody because that question is not
one on one. Now the other piece that I
would break that you pierce the veil on
is we set this up with one on one two
days a week. You guys are Christian,
right? Okay.
The amount of church relationship
communities where it's 10 people in a
room, 20 people 20 couples in a room and
they get up and they talk.
You have AA, super personal, people get
up in front. I think it's a belief that
you have. But like couples problems are
couples problems. So here I was hitting
her from behind. They're not going to
[laughter] They're just going to be
like, "We're having trouble in bed." And
everyone knows what it means. Cuz the
flip side of how I would sell it is
listen, [music] one of the hardest parts
of being a couplepreneur is that it's
lonely. And so wouldn't it be nice to
know that the struggles that you have
are struggles that other people share,
too?
>> True.
>> And to be clear, I would use the exact
examples. Like not going to be saying
like, "What are the positions you're
rotating through?" And like, "Have you
brought a friend in?" I'm kidding. I'm
not. I'm saying like like you're It's
like, "All right, well she threw a wig
on." You know, like
But like no one's like
"Clutch my pearls. They're married."
>> Yeah.
>> Do whatever you want.
And so I think it's a belief thing.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's like you're not talking
erectile dysfunction, you're just
talking about the relationship.
>> Yeah.
>> And those are going to be commonalities.
And I think that long-term they'll
probably feel more kinship the idea that
like they're suffering from the same
business [music] issues. And the
business advice you give helps
everybody. The relationship advice you
give helps everybody. Now there is a
ratio where it stops being small group
and becomes one to many.
>> Yeah.
>> So basically after like I'd say
seven-ish, it's now not enough
individual time. I think if you guys did
one on four
>> [music]
>> and you did uh the 490 minute sessions,
>> Yeah.
>> I think you'd be fine. It's harder to go
from one on one to one to many. So if
you're going to change it, I would just
change it.
>> Okay.
>> What do you think of that, Sarah?
>> If we are currently doing like weekly
group calls and Slack, there's almost
like a constant flow of question and
answering and things like that. If we're
just going to quarterly calls and the
events, there is none of that. It's
almost just the experience of coming
together at the events and then getting
the strategy each quarter. Do you think
there would be any pushback from people
not being able to ask questions on the
strategy that we map out every quarter?
>> Maybe.
>> Okay.
>> Comma, how much does it matter? And so I
think again a lot of this comes down to
framing.
>> Yeah.
>> And so
if I'm going to work with someone for
example, like I'm not going to be like,
"Hey, hit me up whenever." Because the
thing is is that doesn't serve you cuz
that means that I'm making all your
decisions for you, which means that you
never learn. Right? You also never learn
how to prioritize. If every single thing
you just outsource your decision-making
to me, which is not a good life for me
or you.
>> And that has happened.
>> Of course it has. And so, the thinking
process that I would have is by doing it
this way, you'll be fully focused on the
fewest things that matter most. Right?
Anyone can give you more things to do.
It's about doing the fewest things
that'll make the most impact. Just as
much as this for the relationship, as
much as this for the business.
>> Okay.
>> Cuz like your wife, you could probably I
could probably give this list of 10
things, but if you just said thank you
for doing the dishes every single day,
and maybe pick up the kids once a week,
get her some flowers. If you just do
those three things, the marriage is
fixed. Let's just think about how do we
remove everything that's preventing you
from doing that. So, I think a lot of it
it will shift subtly in terms of how
you're presenting it in the pitch, but
I would call that out. If you're the
type of person who's like, "Hey, I want
someone to tell me exactly what to say
to my wife every single day."
Here's the thing, I'm not married to
your wife.
>> Right.
>> You married your wife. And so, if I were
to do that, I would be doing you a
disservice cuz you're never going to
learn.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm just going to be ChatGPT for you for
relationships. Right? And you know what?
You should use ChatGPT for cuz he's not
bad.
>> [laughter]
>> These day-to-day things. What we're here
for is for the big decisions.
>> Yeah.
>> That's where we provide the most value.
>> Okay.
>> Cuz if you look back on your life,
there's a handful of decisions that
created the life you have. And we want
to make the next handful of decisions
exactly what they should be to get to
the life you want.
>> That's fantastic framing cuz I've even
told her too that my brain feels like
ChatGPT because I basically answering
questions all day long.
>> Tell her what to lift.
>> Yeah, it absolutely is. Along the same
lines of that though, the best case
studies we've had of couples are very
blessed to say that we have 20 videos of
just amazing case studies of people
making more money and going on date
nights.
I don't know if that would have been
possible had we not held them
accountable to taking the steps and stay
focused cuz between one quarter to the
next, I mean, you know how much can
shift and people shift priorities,
people get distracted, whatever. So, how
do we mitigate that part?
>> So, I'll give you escape valve and then
another frame. So, escape valve, if you
want, which is Who here has seen or
heard of Who Wants to Be a Millionaire?
So, everybody had three lifelines.
Right? One of them was called friend,
one was you move the statistical. So,
for us
you've got four 911 calls.
Or two.
>> Or [laughter] three.
>> If it's a 911 emergency, then by all
means let us know and we'll figure it
out. But that way it's on an escalation
basis. Again, the goal here isn't for
them to be dependent on you.
>> True.
>> The goal is for them to learn the skills
so that they can get to where they want
to go. Anyone can give you a lot of
things to do, but that assumes unlimited
resources, which you do not have. And
so, realistically, all of you guys here,
let's just be honest, you're going to
dedicate maybe 5% of your time to this.
>> Yeah.
>> So, we want to crush that 5%, so we get
the 80% 180% benefit from it.
>> Yeah. That's the value of strategy.
>> Yeah.
>> And that makes 100% sense too as to why
people aren't renewing cuz they feel
like they haven't used all of the
resources.
>> So, it's actually hurting us on both
angles. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Of course. Planet Fitness figured this
out. But there was this huge amount of
big health clubs, right? And they had
racquetball courts, they had swimming
swimming, they had basketball, they had
weights, they had cardio. But when they
did their research, they found out that
80% of people just used the cardio
mostly and then a little bit of weights.
And so, they said, "Cool, we'll just
cater to the 80% and we'll dramatically
be able to reduce our cost to open
>> Yeah.
>> and be able to reduce the price and
transfer that to the customer." And so,
what happens is when health clubs were
charging $59 a month, $89 a month,
people were still only using those two
things for the most part.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, we think, "Oh, I'm going to add
more stuff to provide more value." But
all you do is create a larger
discrepancy between consumption and lack
of consumption. Look at all the stuff
I'm not using, which means I'm not
getting my money's worth.
>> Exactly.
>> Rather than thinking, "I'm getting all
this for $59." They're just thinking,
"I'm only using 20% of my $59."
>> Yeah.
>> And so, it doesn't matter what the price
point is, people still cancel because
they just think that they're not using
as much of the
>> 100%.
>> So, that's why what I went back to the
bonuses, we want to make sure that the
things that we're putting there are
absolutely going to be used because
they're valuable.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Anyone who's watching this who has a
product, you need to pay attention to
this. [music] So, let's say that you're
have some sort of mini stack. I like the
gym membership cuz it's the simplest
example, right? You've got a spa and
you've got a pool and you've got
basketball court, you've got tennis,
>> [music]
>> you've got weights, you've got cardio.
Right, there's all these things that we
have for one low price of $29.99,
whatever it is, right? The problem is
most people are only going to use one of
these things throughout their entire
career. And so you might think, "Oh, I'm
giving them all this value for $29." But
what they're seeing
is that they're not using this.
And so this is now waste instead of even
added value. And so it's much better to
just give somebody 100% of what the only
thing they want and charge them
appropriately for it. Cuz now they're
getting 100% of what they desire.
>> I know this obviously doesn't fix the
straight problem of our delivery, but
what do you think about doing like small
group monthly instead of quarterly? So
that way it's like setting the plan for
the month, they execute on it, and doing
it every month with [clears throat] four
couples.
>> You'd have the same exact thing as the
one-on-one situation.
>> Yeah.
>> It's easier to change a cadence than it
is to change a ratio.
>> Okay.
>> So if you wanted to start with we do
monthly and it's one on four,
Shel's call. But
>> Okay.
>> You wouldn't do it though.
>> I just prefer to think like it forces
you and it forces them to prioritize.
[music]
>> Yeah, I do like that.
>> Yeah.
>> And for them to make decisions, not rely
upon us.
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> Come to us with the big decisions
[music] that are going to affect your
marriage and business. And our deep dive
in the beginning that we start with is
we're going to be identifying what those
levers are.
>> Yeah.
>> That's what we want to talk about. What
you're having for dinner on Tuesday?
What cool date idea that you're going to
have? We've got resources for that
stuff. You don't need me to tell you you
should do clay pottery or wine and paint
night or whatever the hell you want to
do. You don't need me for that. You
could Google it.
>> Um yeah.
>> The things that I can actually help you
with are going to be the rarer things
that will have the bigger biggest
[music] impact on the life in your life.
>> Yeah.
And that's the highest leverage you
should have.
>> 100%.
>> Yeah.
>> For everybody.
>> And be like, cuz listen, if we were to
do it where it was one-on-one and it was
every single week, we'd have to charge
$200,000 for it. It wouldn't make sense.
So [music] this still gets you the 80/20
of that. And then you get all your time
back.
>> Yeah, I'm loving this.
>> Yeah, I do, too.
>> When Alex clarified exactly what we need
to do, I feel like that's going to lead
to even more bliss in our relationship
because I'm no longer [music] going to
be tied to a lot of client delivery.
Even though we love our clients, it's
going to free up more time for us, and
it creates a much simpler path to hit
our goals as a couple.
>> Yeah, and it allows us to feel like we
can move lock and step in the same
direction towards the goal, and it's a
lot of what we help our clients do. So,
it's cool.
>> Yeah.
>> What would you do with the people that
are currently in that offer? Would you
continue to serve them the same way?
Would you tell them that we're making an
adjustment? Like, how would you
transition that?
>> Here's the great news. Because you
currently don't renew anyone, just
[laughter] wait. The thing is is that
like it doesn't actually matter that
much. So, you can continue to see it
like always keep your commitments. You
made a promise, you keep it. Done.
But in terms of, "Hey, this is what
we're doing going forward," then that's
it's a new agreement.
>> Yep.
>> New terms, new agreement. Believe it or
not, we've actually got a complete stack
because we're good. And so, because of
that, we still want to help you, and we
think this actually is And here's the
thing. And this is where I think people
mess this up. They will try it they will
apologize essentially for saying, "Hey,
we were one-on-one, now we're doing
one-on-four. Sorry, we're just" No. This
is better.
>> Yes.
>> This isn't as good it's better. It's
better cuz you're going to have other
people. You'll hear somebody else's
question be like, "Ooh, that's a good
one. I should have I should have thought
of that." Or I didn't think of that.
Because the thing is is that somebody
might have already solved your problem,
and they're on to the next problem. And
this also is why we don't need to meet
as often because you're going to hear a
higher variety of questions being
answered. So that when you do have that
next problem a month later, you're like,
"Oh, Sandy, I remember what you said to
Sandy. I'm just going to do that."
>> Yeah, that makes a lot of sense. Yeah,
thank you.
>> Let's recap this. B, number one, new
back-end  front-end
offer
is going to be 25K  30K if they
do a payment plan. We're going to do
layaway as a downsell with 3 months,
which is 9K up front. You can also do 10
if you feel like it. And that's going to
come with two times per year in person,
one-on-four quarterly. You can do one
deep dive one-on-one. That's fine. So,
it's like, we're going to do the deep
dive one-on-one with you, and then
you're going to get in the group.
>> Okay.
>> Got it.
>> One-on-one deep dive, and the group. All
right. Second thing is we're going to
test date night angle. So, we're just
going to take your five-day, put it
vertical, eliminate the transitions, and
then crush it. Number three, ads. So,
I'm going to split this into two cuz I
think so we're basically more organic
daily, which goes into ads,
plus ETA at the end. Four,
100 plus images from your camera roll,
and then for renewal, you're going to
set it up, and actually make the offer.
>> Let's [laughter] go.
>> at in person. And the easiest way to do
that is just ask them when they're going
to come back. That's it. This is the
next date.
Let's do it. So, I think that this is
already a 5x
on your price cuz you're going to
probably convert about the same amount
of people, because believe it or not,
>> Fun fact.
>> What matters more for the conversion is
the first payment.
>> Makes
>> $5,000.
This is $9,000 really that you're going
to be positioning as 2,500 to 3,000.
>> Yeah.
>> So, the cash up front is going to be
more or less the same. So, this is me
just trying to get you to believe. All
right. First, I like this angle. This is
the big kind of like unknown.
>> Right.
>> This could be like a 1 to 4x.
>> Okay.
>> Because if this crushes, which I really
feel like it would, like you might just
have a whole new way
>> Yeah.
>> I've selling in the industry. If I were
to enter this industry, I would probably
enter this way.
>> Yeah.
>> Organic daily, this will just improve
your ads.
>> Yeah.
>> So, this could be an easy 1.5x, maybe 2x
if we're lucky, in terms of decreasing
CAC. And then the renewal is just going
to extend out the LTV long term. So,
that's going to be year two, year three
where this is going to matter.
>> Got you.
>> And just to clarify, the renewal since
we're doing this event in a month,
>> Yeah.
>> it would be the renewal to the new style
offer.
>> Yep.
>> Okay, got it.
>> Yeah.
This is a combination of couple of
couples insurance and couples
accelerator.
Downside, you do absolutely nothing and
you come twice a year, we could still
absolutely change your marriage, and
it'll be the moments that you remember
most. On the upside, you actually do the
work with us. I can use these samples I
gave. Hey, I'm been church. The problems
that you have aren't unique. [music] And
so, one of the big things about shame is
it lives in darkness. It makes you feel
like you're alone.
>> Yeah, that's right.
Yeah, I love that. It's great framing.
>> [laughter]
>> I love that. And you also mentioned
resources, too. If people have
questions, hey, we have resources for
that. Would you make that available?
>> you define shame and guilt? Cuz I think
it's probably helpful.
>> Okay.
>> So, shame is when you break
other people's rules that you respect or
care about.
Guilt is when you break your own rules.
So, sometimes, if your rules are the
same as everyone else's, you'll feel
guilt and shame. If you don't think what
you're doing is wrong, but other people
do, you'll just feel ashamed.
>> Yeah.
>> And if you do something that isn't
really wrong in other people's rules,
but it's for yourself, you'll feel
guilty.
>> Guilty, yeah.
>> And so, I would explain that when
someone's like, "I don't want to be in
these other people." I was like, "Let's
just nail this Let's just hit this on
the head." Which is that you're afraid
of being embarrassed. Sure. So, why do
you feel embarrassed? Because you think
you're the only person who deals with
that. And it's self-fulfilling. So, I
think we've done a lot of thought.
>> [laughter]
>> We consulted our elders. And we actually
think that we want to we want to bring
it to the light. We want more people
together, so they realize that this
isn't something to be ashamed of if you
have an issue. And it's normal. And the
only thing that's not normal is that
people think it's not normal.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, I love that reframe.
>> [music]
>> Even the definition of guilt versus
shame. I think it's perfect.
>> How do you feel about the spin?
>> I like it.
>> Love it.
>> feel like you can do it?
>> Of course we can do it.
>> So, coming into this, we had a thousand
different ideas of how we can grow our
business. And we were so excited to hear
from Alex, cuz he has the perspective of
a bunch of different business models and
a bunch of different marketing models.
And now, having got to sit with him, we
feel very clear on what is the next best
step. Out of the thousand things that we
could do, we feel very clear that we
could take the steps that he gave,
implement it, and actually have more
time in the process.
>> So, even as a couple, I think what Alex
equipped us with is going to allow us to
be even more aligned on where we're
going, even more fulfilled, and just
allow us to help and serve even more
couples. So, we're super excited about
it.
>> To put a little bow on everything that
we're going to do with Kyle and Ariel's
business is number one, we're going to
have a new back-end / front-end offer
cuz it's just going to combine it into
one offer. We're going to do a little
deep dive with one on four, so we're
changing the delivery ratio to just give
them exactly what they need and expand
their supply capacity. Number two is
we're going to test the date night
angle. I think it's going to crush.
We'll see, but I feel pretty bullish on
it, especially when they gave me their
reaction that date night was like
people's most favorite thing. I'm like,
"Then let's put that on the front end."
Number three is just being more
consistent with organic so that we can
actually create more testing for free
with ads cuz they're a kind of cash
constrained business. So, the easiest
way to test ads is just post them, see
how they do for organic, and then just
add the CTA later. So, anybody who's
broke, like, consider doing that. Number
four is running a ton of images as
statics for the ads because they had
images that were working better. That's
fine. It's usually because the videos
they make suck, not because images are
more compelling than videos. Videos are
for sure more compelling, but static
images are better because people's
imaginations fill in something that's
compelling rather than a video that they
know wasn't good.
And then finally, we're going to build
more recurring revenue in the business
by having all the renewals occur in
person, which is the highest likelihood
of closing. And so, with those five
changes within the business, I think
they're going to unlock a tremendous
amount of growth. And if you liked this
video, you're going to love this next
video where I break down a different
business so that you can use the same
tactics they did, make all the money,
and then question the meaning of life.